good afternoon welcome to the Whitney
and Betty
various studies apologies for the delay
I think it's in everybody's comfortable
interesting more comfort here my name is
Noah Montero I'm the director of
international security studies here the
associate professor of political science
it's my great pleasure to introduce
professor John J Mira Shimer from the
University of Chicago who happened to be
my dissertation adviser back before the
meteor came and killed all the dinosaurs
this is the second of these three
lectures here today all the lectures are
on the topic of liberal dreams in
international realities today's lecture
will be titled the false promise of
liberal hegemony and needs to be
followed by tomorrow lecture at the same
time in room 203 tomorrow notice to the
changing room also upstairs but the
other room tomorrow's lecture is titled
the case for restraint and it will be
followed by a reception we hope to see
you here again tomorrow thank you thank
you very much for the introduction Nuno
and thank you again to Ian for inviting
me to give the Stimpson lectures it's
truly a pleasure to be here and it's
also an honor to deliver these lectures
at an August institution like Yale I
also as a good Marxist in the Groucho
Marx sense of the term and deeply
humbled that so many people turned out
to hear me talk that we had to change
the venue so thank you very much I hope
I can deliver a lecture that makes it
all worth it as Nuno said tonight I'm
going to talk about the false promise of
liberal hegemony for those of you who
were here on Monday night you know that
what I did was I really talked about
liberalism and didn't say much about
foreign policy this is the first of my
two talks tonight and tomorrow night
that really do with the International
dimension of liberalism the first talk
was all about just sort of getting at
the essence of liberalism the outline
for tonight is that I'd like to start by
defining what I mean by liberal head
and explain to you why states pursue it
then I'd like to explain when states
pursue liberal hegemony so the first
part will deal with the why the second
part is when and then in the third part
I want to talk about what it looks like
in practice
and then finally explain to you why it
is prone to fail disastrously so the
first part of the talk is on the subject
of what is liberal hegemony just a few
words about its policy relevance then
what I really want to do is talk about
its theoretical underpinnings with
regard to its policy relevance I think
almost everybody who studies IR in my
world agrees that it has been the
foreign policy of the United States
since the Cold War ended that the United
States has pursued liberal hegemony and
for those who have any doubts the
argument usually goes that it wasn't
really true up until 2001 but clearly it
was true after 2001 but most people
agree that during the entire Cold War
period it has been the foreign policy of
choice and moreover it's a foreign
policy that the American elite loves as
I said the other night we sometimes
refer to the American foreign policy
establishment as the blob this has been
roads as terminology Ben Rhodes who
worked for Barack Obama the blob is
deeply wedded to liberal hegemony and it
includes both Republicans and Democrats
there's this myth in the land mainly
pervade by Republicans that Republicans
and Democrats have very different views
on foreign policy
this is poppycock it's Tweedledee and
Tweedledum right and they loved their
they loved their liberal hegemony Donald
Trump is an exception he ran against
liberal hegemony and where he ends up
remains to be seen but he ran against it
now a little bit about the analytical
foundation of liberal hegemony and this
grows out of my discussion from last
time as I said to you liberalism is at
its root a political philosophy that
focuses on the individual and places
enormous emphasis on inalienable rights
inalienable meaning they apply to
everybody and they cannot be taken away
and the point that I made last time and
I'd like to emphasize again tonight is
when you marry that sense of
individualism with inalienable rights
you get a Universalist ideology right
and the point I made last time and make
again here is that you is that liberal
hegemony or even liberalism when it
applies to foreign policy has this
Universalist dimension that is of great
importance and what it means in terms of
a broad foreign policy goal is that you
quickly become consumed with spreading
liberal democracy across the globe that
emphasis on inalienable rights which
leads to universalism produces a foreign
policy that emphasizes the spreading of
liberal democracy and there are three
reasons for that this really gets to the
heart and soul of the argument and I'll
unpack them all but just put them up in
laundry lists fashion right now you want
to spread democracy for three reasons
one to protect human rights across the
world 2 to cause international peace and
three to protect liberalism at home and
again all of this grows out of the
emphasis on individualism and
inalienable rights as I'll make clear as
we go along here so let me start by
talking about protecting human rights
across the world
the basic argument is that people who
live in a far-off country are no
different that people who live in your
country borders actually don't matter
very much rights are of great importance
and everybody has rights and when the
rights of non Americans are being
threatened
Americans have a responsibility to do
everything they can to protect those
people whose rights are being violated
and of course the most important here
important right here is the right to
life if some foreign dictator is
murdering large numbers of his or her
people the United States has a
responsibility it grows out of this
universalism to protect the rights of
those individuals that are being
violated now this goes so far in the
liberal discourse that you end up
getting the argument that non liberal
governments are in a state of aggression
with their own people just think about
that statement this is Michael Doyle
mainstream prominent liberal
international relations theorist at
Columbia University it's basically
saying non liberal government's no
matter what they do
non liberal governments are in a state
of aggression with their own people what
happens here is that you go from a
situation where you can use your
military forces to intervene in
different countries when there are gross
violations of individual rights and fix
the problem and then leave you go from
that more modest policy to one where you
decide that the best way to protect
rights is
to turn another country into a liberal
democracy because once it's a liberal
democracy the individual rights which
are privileged in liberalism are
protected by definition so if you have a
planet that is filled with nothing but
liberal democracies the problem of gross
violations of human rights is simply
taken off the table if you merely just
act like a fire department and you only
intervene in those situations where you
see rights being violated you fix it and
then you get out you don't ultimately
solve the problem so what this emphasis
on protecting rights does especially
when it's taken in the form that Michael
Doyle lays out it leads to the belief
that what you want to do is populate the
planet with liberal democracies second
reason to spread liberal democracy it
leads to international peace virtually
everybody in this audience I'm sure
knows all about Democratic peace theory
Democratic peace theory is based on the
basic liberal template involving rights
and tolerance right it's the whole idea
that people across the planet have a set
of inalienable rights and that they tend
to respect the rights of other
individuals right and that leads to
international peace right if you can
spread democracy across the planet in
other words you create a world of all
democracies they're not going to fight
against each other because people
respect the rights of people in other
countries and they're tolerant the
tolerance grows out of that emphasis on
inalienable rights as I talked about
last time this is basic democratic peace
theory and this
the basic liberal logic that underpins
it moreover it solves the twin problems
of nuclear proliferation and terrorism
but if you have peace
you don't need nuclear weapons there's
no need for global but for nuclear
weapons in a world where there's nothing
but liberal democracies and terrorism is
certainly not going to be a problem
because in the liberal story liberal
states never engage in terrorism it's
always non liberal States so the idea is
to create a world where they're just
liberal democracies and this is the
rationale for invading Iraq sometimes
people will say to me John how can you
say that invading Iraq was based on a
liberal theory
well the invasion of Iraq and the Bush
Doctrine more generally as I made clear
as we go along here was based on the
assumption that if you could go into
Iraq go into Iran go into Syria you
could turn them greater Middle East into
a sea of democracies you could turn them
into a sea of democracies cause peace
there would be no nuclear proliferation
and there would be no terrorism that's
what they thought would be the end
result this is why the Bush
administration thought that al-qaeda
itself was not the problem
al-qaeda was part of the problem but
rogue states in the Middle East rogue
states meaning non-democracies that
don't dance to America's tune have to be
turned into liberal democracies so once
that happens then you turn the Middle
East into his own of peace and oh by the
way this is exactly what happened in
Europe according to the liberal story
why do we have peace in Europe because
it's filled with liberal democracies and
I'll talk more about this in the context
of NATO expansion they don't fight each
other you don't get terrorism you don't
get nuclear proliferation third oh me
yeah just on the business of
international peace but you also see in
the literature on liberal democracy is a
cause of peace there's a tremendous
emphasis on the word
community especially international
community you surely have all heard the
word international community many times
international community is very much a
liberal term think about the opposite of
international its national when the
journal journal International Security
was created there was a huge debate
about whether to call it national
security or international security and
they called the International Security
right international right and it's the
international community giving you the
sense that there are really no
meaningful borders among the states that
exist in that community those borders
are very porous we talked about the
transatlantic community we talked about
the European community the EC we went
from the European stealing coal
community to the European community to
the European Union right but the
European community we talk about
security communities Karl Deutsch is
famous term Woodrow Wilson used to talk
about communities of power right and of
course in these communities you're not
going to have any war that's the basic
argument third reason the spread liberal
democracy is to protect liberalism at
home the fact is that virtually every
liberal theorists understands that
you're not going to convince every
single person in a liberal society that
liberalism is the ideal political system
and there's always a danger on the home
front that there'll be a group that is
powerful and will attempt to overthrow
the liberal order and what really scares
liberals is the thought that that group
on the home front will form an alliance
with a foreign country and that foreign
country will help fuel revolution at
home okay so if you live in a world of
all liberal democracies that problem is
taken off the table that's reflected in
Woodrow Wilson's famous words
he went before Congress on April 2nd
1917 to ask for a declaration of war
against Germany and that's where he made
his famous remarks that his aim was to
help create a world that could be made
safe for democracy a world that could be
made safe for democracy
because he understood that liberal
democracy sometimes exists in a tenuous
state it's to give you two other
examples of this the United States and
the Red Scare is after both World War
one and during the early Cold War was
the basic fear here the basic fear was
that there were communists in the United
States and those communists would ally
with a communist state like the Soviet
Union and the end result of that would
be trouble if not revolution on the home
front so if you can create a situation
when you turn the Soviet Union into a
liberal democracy you turn communist
China into a liberal democracy you just
take that problem right off the table
and think about the problem today from
China and Russia's point of view with
China and Russia today fear is the
liberal groups in individuals inside
those countries who are unhappy with the
likes of Vladimir Putin will Alai with
the United States to undermine the
regime you go to Moscow today you go to
Beijing today they are really worried
about regime change hard as that may to
be believed that may be to believe
regime change instigated by the United
States in an alliance with liberal
forces inside their own countries and
again if the United States was not a
liberal country this problem would be
taken off the table so the underpinnings
of liberal hegemony emphasis on
individualism plus and alia Beloit's
gives it a powerful Universalist impulse
and that impulse leads to a foreign
policy committed to spreading liberal
democracy around the world
old for those three reasons when the
states pursue liberal agenda this is the
second big question my argument is it
depends largely on the structure of the
system
it depends largely on whether or not the
system is bipolar multi polar or
unipolar if it's bipolar or multi polar
in other words there are if there are
two or more great powers in the system
States cannot pursue their blue jimminy
they have to act according to balance of
power logic and in a minute I'm going to
explain to you why that is completely
consistent with liberal theory but just
for now understand that my argument is
when there are two or more great powers
each of those great powers has to worry
about the other great power and
therefore has to worry about the balance
of power and has to act according to
balance of power logic in the unipolar
system where there is a single great
power a single great power this is the
United States of course when the cold
war ends you could pursue liberal Gemma
T because you don't have to worry about
the balance of power because there is
effectively no balance of power you are
Godzilla and you are free to do pretty
much what you want and you understand
what's happening here
if you're Godzilla and you have this
liberal impulse hardwired into you you
know what you're going to do you're
going to try and create democracy all
over the world I'll say more about that
in a second but unipolarity
is where you get liberal hegemony and as
I said this is consistent with the
liberal formula for dealing with
conflict remember what I said last time
liberalism at its root is a theory of
conflict liberals assume
do you have individuals and those
individuals cannot agree on first
principles in all cases and sometimes
the disagreement over first principles
is so powerful that people want to kill
each other and that is why you need the
Nightwatchman state there's no liberal
theorist who says you don't need a state
the three-part solution or formula for
preventing conflict is number one
inalienable rights if everybody has
rights and everybody has the right to
life I'm not gonna be a lot of killing
if you can convince people that
furthermore there's going to be a lot of
tolerance so purveying the norm of
Tolerance is very important in the
liberal story but all liberals
understand that emphasizing rights and
emphasizing tolerance those two things
together is not enough you need a night
watchman state think about the state of
nature liberals start in the state of
nature where individuals are constantly
in a situation with its potential for
conflict and death and what they do is
they form a social contract and the
social contract involves a higher
authority so you need that higher
authority there's no higher authority in
international politics there is no world
state there's no social contract despite
all this talk about community therefore
if you're surrounded by other great
powers you have no choice but to compete
with them according to liberal logic
because according to liberal logic
without the Nightwatchman state you are
back in the state of nature the state of
nature is Antarctic it's not high Arctic
the reason you form a state a social
contract is to get out of Anarchy but
you don't have that in international
politics and for that reason when there
are other great powers in the system you
have to compete with them and you can't
pursue liberal hegemony but if you're in
unipolarity the imbalance is so great
between Godzilla
and all of the minions the Godzilla is
free to pursue liberal hegemony that's
the basic argument they take this one
step further
you know Montero as you know has written
the seminal book on unipolarity and he
says in that book that the Unipol has
three options if you think about it
these make perfect sense
first of all the Unipol can go home
because it's so powerful and secure that
it doesn't have to sweat what's going on
in the rest of the world you just go
home you won we won the Cold War
we're Godzilla let's go home who's gonna
threaten us and if the minions want to
fight among themselves who cares that's
one possibility
second is you can stay involved abroad
and use the power you have to maintain
the status quo or number three you can
stay involved abroad and use that power
to do social engineering on a grand
scale that number three is what Uncle
Sam did because Uncle Sam has this
liberal impulse hardwired into it and
and of course how does the capability in
terms of raw power and as I pointed out
to you last time social engineering is
at the heart of modern liberalism modern
liberalism is all about social
engineering and modern liberals have
great confidence in social engineering
so when you put the distribution of
power this liberal DNA which involves
this Universalist impulse and your
belief in social engineering you're off
to the races and that's exactly what
happened after 1989 talk a little bit
about liberal hegemony and action you
get as I just said you get a super
ambitious foreign policy you also get a
heavily militarized
foreign policy the United States is a
militaristic state it's really quite
remarkable I'll talk more about this as
we go along we're addicted to war and
these are liberal driven Wars I'll talk
a little bit about this tomorrow
me and my realest friends have been
against almost every one of these wars
and it's my liberal friends who are
pushing these Wars I have some liberal
friends who have never seen a war they
didn't want to fight we have a highly
militarized foreign policy the United
States is forth seven separate wars
since the Cold War ended and it's been
war at war for two out of every three
years since 1980 on it this is
remarkable
coming back to Nuno's template I thought
we won the Cold War we could go home and
relax
we're so powerful but no no no that's
not what we did and we did it for
liberal reasons liberal hegemony action
to cases just talk a little bit about
NATO expansion as you know when the Cold
War ended shortly thereafter in the
Clinton administration they began to
talk about expanding NATO and does that
make clear as we go along here this is
the one of the principal causes of the
conflict with Russia over Ukraine the
first expansion was in 1999 we brought
in Poland Hungary and the Czech Republic
the second expansion was in 2004 we
brought in the Baltic States Romania
Slovenia Slovakia so forth and so on and
then after 2008 we were talking about
bringing in Ukraine and Georgia now when
things blew up after the February 22nd
2014 coup in Ukraine when things blow up
between us and the Russians they took
Crimea so forth and so on everybody said
the Russians are a threat to overrun
Eastern Europe the whole purpose of NATO
expansion was to contain Russia and
thank goodness we were actually moving
further in for
into Eastern Europe that's simply not
true that's simply not true there's no
evidence to support that argument we
were moving NATO eastward in large part
as an element in a liberal strategy that
was designed to take this security
community in the deutschen sense of the
term we had created in Western Europe
during the Cold War and move it eastward
it included not only spreading NATO it
included spreading the European Union
and promoting democracy you all remember
the orange revolution in Ukraine and you
remember the Rose Revolution in Georgia
this was all designed to take this
security community and move it eastward
Michael McFaul who I've debated on this
issue of the Ukraine crisis who was the
US ambassador to Russia from 2012 to
right before the 2014 coup says that I
told Putin on numerous occasions and I
told his lieutenants on numerous
occasions that NATO expansion was not a
threat to Russia and he genuinely
believed that Barack Obama has said the
same thing he genuinely believed it
these people who were pushing NATO
expansion did not believe in realpolitik
and containment in fact they said that
anyone who believes in realpolitik in
containment and that includes yours
truly is a seventeenth-century person
that's right
we're dinosaurs that world has gone away
with the end of the Cold War
so NATO expansion was not motivated by
realist logic and by the way virtually
all the realists were opposed to NATO
expansion and said this is not going to
have a happy ending and George Kennan
gave a famous interview to Thomas
Friedman of the New York Times who wrote
it up and Kennedy said exactly that this
is unnecessary and it's good a link to
big trouble and surprise of surprises it
led to a war in August 2008 between
Russia and Georgia and in 2014 who ended
up with a war between Russia and Ukraine
over Ukraine
right but it was not driven by realist
logic bush doctrine you know a lot of
people will say what's going on in the
Middle East or the greater Middle East
is that we are pursuing the American
national interest in a realpolitik kind
of way and just disguising our behavior
with liberal rhetoric in fact if you
look at what the Bush administration
said that's not true and as I explained
to you about the Iraq case we went into
Iraq for the purpose of turning it into
a liberal democracy because we saw that
as part of a story where there would be
no more war in the Middle East once we
got beyond Iraq we got Syria involved
and Iran involved if we democratize the
entire place it would all lead to peace
love and dope and it would take
terrorism and nuclear proliferation off
the table that was the basic view here
of what we were up to of course it all
crashed and burned but but that was the
initial intention and by the way it was
a remarkably ambitious foreign policy I
can think of no case in American history
where we pursued a foreign policy that
was as ambitious and foolish is this the
idea that we were going to democratize
the Middle East region of the world that
had hardly any history of democracy at
the end of a rifle barrel really
remarkable and of course who opposed
that war mainly realest some liberals
did much to their credit but mainly
realists
why is liberal hegemony doomed reason
number one social engineering and
foreign countries is an extremely
difficult Enterprise under the best of
circumstances
and these social engineering in one's
own country is especially difficult but
the idea that we can go into a foreign
country we can go into a foreign country
where most of the people don't speak the
language don't understand the culture
knock off the regime right and therefore
create a lot of chaos and then create
order out of that chaos and not just
order out of that chaos but create
liberal democracy or even just democracy
this is a pipe dream and using the US
military for that I spent 10 years of my
life in the US military I went to West
Point the US military the US Army is
ground forces that we have they're good
at breaking things they're good at
killing people they're giant killing
machines the idea that you could take
the US Army and send it into Iraq and
that it is going to be able to do nation
building or state building in a
sophisticated way it's not going to
happen I can guarantee you you want to
send him up against Saddam's army in the
middle of the desert in 1991 right you
want to do that
that's Bambi versus Godzilla right
that's what the US Army or the US
Marines are good at doing right but you
start talking about taking the American
military putting it at a place like
Vietnam putting in a place like
Afghanistan and letting it do social
engineering not gonna work right I don't
care if you bring in experts is not
gonna work anyway and if it does work
it's gonna take you a heck of a long
time but there are three other reasons
it's not gonna work
second is nationalism is a remarkably
powerful force you've heard me say that
on more than one occasion between the
last lecture and this one and it causes
the target state to resist foreign
intervention I won't go into a long song
and dance about what nationalism is all
about I'd love to do that but let me
just say self-determination and
sovereignty are at the heart of
nationalism the people in a nation-state
the nation itself and the leaders who
run a state they want to determine for
themselves what their domestic politics
look like and they want to determine for
themselves what their foreign policy
looks like this is what sovereignty is
all about and they don't want a foreign
country whether it's the United States
or the Soviet Union going into
Afghanistan or Britain going into
Afghanistan or France going into Vietnam
these people don't want foreigners
running their politics they don't want
foreigners occupying their country and
who can blame them as I point out here
think about the u.s. outrage over claims
that the Russians interfered in the 2016
election apparently from reading the
newspapers this drives Americans crazy
the idea that the Russians interfered in
our elections
well we interfere in elections all over
the planet we interfere in the politics
of states all over the planet we think
we have a god-given right to go into any
country violent sovereignty if it's done
for just purposes which means promoting
liberal democracy we have a rich history
of it as you know but as my mother
taught me when I was a little boy what's
good for the goose is good for the
gander if we if we're jealous gods when
it comes to our sovereignty don't you
think that people in other countries I'm
going to feel the same way don't you
think the Vietnamese after World War two
we're gonna want the French out and then
when the Americans replaced the French
don't you think they're gonna want us
out
they are do you think the Afghani czar
happy about costs being there
you think that this is a long-term
solution but you may believe we can do
the necessary social engineering to fix
the problem getting back to my first
point don't bet on it
you understand that Afghanistan is the
longest war in American history and we
have now spent quite a bit more money on
fixing Afghanistan than we spent with
the Marshall Plan and look at the
results not pretty reason number three
individual rights this whole concept of
Analia below verse old if you sort of
look around the world at surveys and you
look at a number of historical cases
what you see is that people generally
think rights are important but they
don't privilege them to the extent that
the theory says they should and people
will often sacrifice rights for
stability there's a lot of survey data
that shows that this is true today in
the Middle East hardly surprising if you
lived in one of those countries would
you that the United States has helped
Trek would you be interested first and
foremost in creating liberal democracy
or would you be interested first and
foremost and creating some stability I
think the answer is quite clear go to
Russia today right first time I ever
went to Russia I talked to all sorts of
people about this issue how do you think
about liberal democracy liberal
democracy means one thing to them the
1990s tried that been there and it was a
total disaster thank God we have Putin
if he's not a Liberal Democrat and he is
a semi authoritarian leader more power
to them that's the answer you hear most
of the time
can you blame them but what this means
is that liberal democracy is not always
an easy sell it's not like you're going
abroad and everybody's out there just
demanding liberal democracy oh my god
this is the most important political
system in the world and if we can just
get it we'll live happily ever after
this is not to say that there aren't
many places where they would prefer
liberal democracy over some semi
authoritarian system there are cases
like that
but the point is it's not an easy sell
and then finally some states actually
act to balance against the unipole they
act according to realist logic this
certainly has been true with China and
Russia and also with Iran and North
Korea I'm going to talk a little bit
more about NATO expansion in a second
the Russians view NATO expansion from a
purely realpolitik point of view this
balance of power politics
yeah idea that the United States can
take a military alliance that was a
mortal enemy of the Soviet Union and
March it up to Russia's doorstep and
make Ukraine and Georgia part of the
West it not going to happen
they'll tell you that it is not going to
happen for balance of power reasons and
all you have to do was talk about the
Chinese about the presence of the
American military in East Asia it
bothers them greatly they do not like
the idea of us being on their doorstep
and they'll tell you behind closed doors
they intend to push us eventually out
beyond the first island chain and then
out beyond the second island chain and I
don't blame them one bit but I'm just
telling you if you're interested in
selling liberal hegemony to major powers
in the system like Russia and China you
ought to understand that there are real
limits to what you can do and then of
course you have minor powers like Iran
and North Korea look at what North Korea
is doing today people say oh what North
Korea is doing today is crazy they're
irrational Kim jong-un we've never seen
anybody this crazy the thought of him
having nuclear weapons is horrified I'd
make a case that what Kim jong-un is
doing is very reasonable
if I were Kim jong-un I have nuclear
weapons and I'd never ever get rid of
them never why because the United States
is running around the world knocking you
off regimes
that's what liberal hegemony is all
about that means if you're not a liberal
hegemonic state think about what Michael
Doyle said you could be in the
crosshairs and how do you prevent regime
change the best way to do this have
nuclear weapons we don't like that for
understandable reasons but from their
point of view it makes them initely good
sense Iran I've said in public on a
number of the
Cajuns if I was the Iranian National
Security Advisor they'd already have
nuclear weapons and I can guarantee you
that if they had nuclear weapons the
Americans and the Israelis would not be
threatening them very simple but the
point that I'm trying to make to you
here is that some states resist not all
of them but some some were foolish like
Colonel Qaddafi we promised Colonel
Qaddafi that if he gave up his WMD
programs we'd leave Malone you know
where he is now he's six feet under six
feet under very foolish bottom line here
bottom line here is if you can balance
balance and some figure that out so
anyway my basic argument is that liberal
agenda is doomed because social
engineering is wickedly difficult
nationalism causes significant
resistance individuals right individual
rights matter but not that much
and it should be number for realism
remains a key factor for some states
some states talk a little bit about the
Ukraine crisis as I said you before NATO
expansion EU expansion and spreading
democracy were all about all about
enlarging the security community that
existed in Western Europe and there was
even thoughts of eventually bringing the
Russians in it was not balance of power
politics but what happened is that after
the April 2008 NATO summit in Bucharest
where we said that Georgia and Ukraine
would become part of NATO you had
shortly thereafter in August 2008 a war
over Georgia and then in 2014 you had
the war over Ukraine 2008 April 2008
look at the communique that was issued
after the Bucharest NATO summit it said
that Georgia and Ukraine will become
part of NATO and you have wars
involving both of those countries and
the Russians have no intention of
letting either Georgia or Ukraine become
part of the West they'll wreck both
those countries before they let it
happen this basic geopolitics and what's
happened to Putin Putin's standing has
gone up significantly
why basic nationalism nationalism at
home factors driving the Russian
behavior realism 101 nationalism and
stability over rights that's the Russian
story it's why you so hard to sell
liberal democracy in Russia the last
consideration and why the Ukraine crisis
happened first point and second point
about nationalism is why Putin is so
popular talk a little bit about the Bush
Doctrine there are five countries that
were the main targets of regime change
we actually use military force in
Afghanistan Iraq and Libya in the case
of Syria we provided huge amounts of
money and training to the rebels we were
deeply committed to overthrowing the
government in Damascus the Assad
government if you read the newspapers in
the United States what you see is people
constantly beating Barack Obama and
Hillary Clinton over the head for not
doing anything to get rid of the regime
in Damascus this is simply wrong we did
not intervene with our own military
forces in any meaningful way but we were
behind we were behind the insurgency in
a major way we were deeply committed to
regime change in Syria and we were also
involved in regime change in Egypt we
helped get rid of Mubarak and then when
the Muslim Brotherhood won a democratic
election we helped usher that leader
Mohamed Morsi out of power
when the Egyptian people
the United States became disenchanted
with Morsi but if you just sort of look
at those five cases Afghanistan is a
disaster zone Iraq another disaster zone
Libya another disaster zone Syria
another disaster zone
and although we had a brief interregnum
where we had liberal democracy or
democracy in Egypt that lasted about a
year and now we're back to where we have
a thug in power who we're comfortable
supporting right this is an abysmal
track rate think of all the death and
destruction in the Middle East since
2001 it's really stunning really
stunning this is all in my opinion this
is all due to local factors plus in a
really big way liberal hegemony the
United States has played a key role in
almost all of those cases Egypt is the
only possible exception and causing a
huge amount of murder and ma'am right
local factors mattered I don't deny that
but the United States played it is
enormous ly important wrong Bush
Doctrine why did it fail difficulty of
doing social engineering social
engineering in Iraq social engineering
in Afghanistan good luck so I think I
said in the Q&A period last time when
the Soviets invaded Afghanistan in 1979
virtually all of my colleagues in the
National Security community were at gas
they said oh my god the Soviets around
the March this is terrible right we've
been weakened 1970s thought that my view
was exactly the opposite the Soviets
invading Afghanistan was the best news
the United States could have had they
just jumped into a giant quagmire it's
like us going into Vietnam one needs to
go to China in the early 2000s I used to
tell the Chinese what you really want to
do is tell the Americans that they have
to win the war on terror you're counting
on them to win the war on terror and
they have to stay in Afghanistan Iraq
till they win the war on
right that'll be forever right and
meanwhile you sit on the sidelines and
just continue to get richer and richer
last thing you want to do if your China
is end up in Vietnam or Afghanistan or
Iraq these are places you want to stay
out of for the reasons I said difficulty
of doing social engineering nationalism
and the fact that most people certainly
at this point in time privilege
stability over rights
bottom line liberal hegemony leads to
one failure after another and this is
one of the reasons ladies and gentlemen
that Donald Trump is president the
United States he explicitly challenged
almost every aspect of liberal hegemony
during the 2016 campaign almost every
aspect how it all turns out with him I
don't know but there's a great deal of
disenchantment in the body populace in
this country the elites as I told you
they love liberal hegemony but the body
politic not so clear a lot of
disenchantment and I believe that this
contributed I don't think it was the
main reason by any means but I think
this contributed to the election of
Donald Trump let me conclude with one
final point which I think is of great
significance I think that liberal
hegemony undermines liberalism at home
it threatens core American values
because America becomes a militarized
state you get this huge national
security state and especially when
you're fighting a global war on terror
and you think you definitely have to
monitor what people in the society are
doing you have to turn the National
Security Agency loose two monitors
peoples monitor people's emails and
telephone conversations and so forth and
so on
so I think that founding fathers
understood James Madison in particular
no nation can preserve its freedom in
the midst of continual warfare
and we live in a country that's engaged
in continual warfare and it's engaged in
continual warfare because we have
decided to pursue a policy of liberal
hegemony and that was not necessary as
Nuno said when you're in unipolarity you
have three choices three very different
choices three stark choices and we
decided to do massive social engineering
at the end of a rifle barrel we tried to
create a planet that's filled with
liberal democracies and it failed and
that's where we are today
thank you I'll be happy to take
questions his question was how did I
overcome the temptation to become a
member of the State Department it was
very simple it's the way I'm
constitutionally wired I hate Authority
it's why I love being an academic as
some of you have heard me say I went to
West Point as an undergraduate and I
really hated it I'm very thankful I went
there because I learned all sorts of
important lessons but I always tell
people that I actually hated going to
West Point and I hated the military
because I hate guns I hate sleeping in
the woods I hate shaving
I hate uniforms but most importantly I
hate Authority so academia was the ideal
place for me and there was no hope that
I could function in a meaningful way in
the State Department because I'd have to
take orders from somebody
religion in this dynamic his question is
could I say something about the role of
religion I downplay religion in my story
obviously which is what prompted your
question if I were to talk about
religion I would embed it in the
discussion of nationalism okay and my
argument is that when you begin to sort
of unpack the concept of nationalism and
get it its essence you have to talk
about culture right well all these
nations have particular cultures and
cultures are all about different
practices and beliefs okay so one set of
beliefs that you can have involve
religion Sam Huntington has written a
book called who are we that argues that
the United States at its root is a white
anglo-saxon Protestant country and that
has not changed in any fundamental way
and he's talking about nationalism and
he's taking that argument about
Protestantism and he is integrating it
into nationalism right if you were to
look at a country like Iran it's obvious
that when you talk about Iranian
nationalism you have to incorporate
religion into it okay now I think where
the real conflict comes up the
intellectual conflict comes up on this
issue is that there are a lot of people
who believe that religion transcends
boundaries and matters in very important
ways so to go to another book that Sam
Huntington wrote which is the clash of
civilizations right when he talked about
Islam versus Christianity
right this Western civilization that
where Christianity really matters in
this Islamic civilization religion is of
great importance right and the fault
lines in his story in that book involve
religion I don't think that theory of
his explains how the world works hardly
at all
because I view the world as based on the
system of nation-states I made this
point to you folks in the previous
lecture if you look at the planet looks
differently you look at Western Europe
where you look at Europe in 1450 right
look at a map of Europe in 1450 they're
due she's principalities empires
city-states wide assortment of different
kinds of political orders there are no
states today if you look at the entire
planet it's populated by nothing but
nation-states nothing but nation-states
nationalism is an incredibly powerful
force so I subordinate religion to
nationalism right and when I hear you
know about how in the Middle East we
have this Islamic force that's arrayed
against us you know I said we went in to
rescue Kuwait which was an Islamic
country that was invaded by Iraq which
is a Lama country between 1980 and 1988
Iran in Iraq for this incredibly bloody
war Saudi Arabia and Iran today are both
Islamic countries then you could say
Shia versus Sunni final point to you is
you should look at the literature on the
30 Years War 1618 to 1648 there's a book
out from Harvard University Press by
Peter Wilson very interesting book and
the question you should ask yourself
when you read the book is how much of
the 30 Years War which is you know in
the aftermath of the Reformation and
where you would expect religion to
really matter big time how much of the
conflict is driven by religion and how
much of it is driven by basic balance of
power politics it's actually surprising
how little religion matters
in my opinion I don't want to be so
foolish as to say religion didn't matter
at all and in fact this is a case where
if religion was going to matter this is
the place you would expect it to matter
right but in fact religion often times
in the story gets subordinated to just
good old-fashioned balance of power
politics so all this is to say I kind of
downplay the importance of religion okay
let me repeat your question for
everybody and you correct me or fill in
the blanks if I don't exactly red
represent your question he's basically
challenging me on the point that NATO
expansion caused the Russian reaction
over Georgia and over Ukraine and he's
saying that there's evidence before 2008
which is the key point that we both
agree on before 2008 there was evidence
of Russian aggression he said for
example there's the case of Chechnya
right and he said there's evidence that
the Russians had plans to invade Crimea
and Ukraine before the 2008 crisis and
Georgia before the 2008 crisis okay I
disagree with you and here's why first
of all Chechnya is inside
rusha it's not outside so that's not
evidence of aggression secondly I've
spent an enormous amount of time trying
to find evidence that the Russians had
contingency plans for taking Crimea
before February 22nd 2014 I can find no
evidence
yes what we're talking about after 1990
I just I think there's no evidence of
Russian aggression and just if you look
at the deployment of Russian forces in
the western districts of Russia there
are hardly any military forces there in
February of 2014 and in fact if you look
at the Russian case and by the way if
you go to Russia today you'll find the
same thing the Russians do not want an
arms race with the West they do not want
an arms race with the United States and
they don't want an arms race with the
United States because they understand
that we've got the Soviet Union into
trouble was that the Soviet Union spent
much too much money on defense and not
enough money on refurbishing the economy
and this is a country that is in
economic trouble it's a giant gas
station they understand that they have
to modernize the arm modernize the
economy and that involves spending lots
of money and you can't do that if you're
fighting wars with the West furthermore
I believe the Russians especially Putin
are very sophisticated strategists and
they understand full well that the last
thing they want to do is invade a
country in Eastern Europe and occupy it
it would be the height of foolishness
right I often say to people if you
really want to wreck Russia what you
ought to do is encourage them to invade
a couple countries in Eastern Europe
let's see how that works out
not very well or if you don't like that
you can have them invade Afghanistan
again they can go in and take over for
us right I think the Russians understand
this that that expansion this is this is
the power of nationalism you know I've
made the argument on a number of
occasions the two principle blocks
against military aggression today are
number one nuclear weapons and number
two nationalism nationalism makes it
very hard to conquer countries
especially if you have to occupy and I
think the Russians fully understand this
I'll just say one final point on this
Russia is a declining great power
largely for demographic reasons but also
for economic reasons just look at the
demographic print the projected
demographic curves
big trouble big trouble on the horizon
interventions and secondly you said that
nationalism but we've seen that national
entities such as themselves do not so
for example we could see NATO major
expansion
eastwards you could see it as an
expansion sovereign spy okay you have to
be shorter I'll take your second point
just quickly my argument which I did not
expand on just because of time is that
states care greatly about their own
sovereignty but great powers especially
violate the sovereignty of other
countries all the time okay pardon oh
it's not only liberal hegemony that
behaves that way that may be true but
nevertheless if you're going to pursue a
policy of liberal hegemony you want to
understand that when you invade other
countries you're going to bump up
against nationalism that was my point
but you're absolutely right I mean we
went into Vietnam a remarkably foolish
decision right because we believed in
the domino theory which is a sort of a
misguided realist view of the world we
didn't go in there for purposes of
promoting liberal democracy but still it
happened there what was your first point
again about values
yeah well I think the most powerful
point you made it's the most difficult
for me to deal with is your point that
we actually made liberal democracy work
in West Germany during the Cold War and
again as I said in the talk we created
this zone of liberal democracies in
Western Europe and then your other point
was South Korea were eventually in South
Korea took quite a while
we got a liberal democracy and just make
a couple points just stick to Western
Europe first of all we were an occupier
in Western Europe especially in Germany
but we were an occupier in large part
because there was this thing there
called the Soviet threat that the West
Europeans feared greatly the Americans
feared greatly and the West Europeans
wanted us there to protect them that's
point number one point number two is
just to take Germany Germany actually
had a rich history of democracy right
vimar Germany was a liberal democracy
and there's a whole literature that
argues that Germany was a democracy a
liberal democracy before World War one
now that's a disputed claim but there
are people who make that argument so it
was not that difficult given that
Germany had been destroyed number one
given the fact that Germany needed us to
protect them against the Soviet Union or
at least they thought they did and
number three that they had a history of
democracy for us to make it work there
right so there are circumstances where
it can be made to work very unusual
circumstances but what happens in the
cases that we're talking about is you
get the United States invading countries
that have hardly any history of
democracy don't face external threats
except from us
right and it therefore becomes very
difficult
yes yeah in countries that are lacking
in the history Liberal Democratic
history and where there's a really high
level of internecine violence Iraq Syria
maybe to a lesser extent Burma these
days what would your theories say about
whether it would be better or worse for
those countries to maintain their
territorial integrity or to split apart
I don't have anything to say about that
in my theories so to speak I mean I have
views on those subjects no I mean not
not as part of the argument that I'm
making up here I mean I I had all sorts
of views and wrote about this in the
1990s with regard to Yugoslavia but we'd
really get off the trail if I started
talking about that and I'm not sure I
could remember everything I said at the
time well the Japanese case is similar
to the German case first of all Japan
was destroyed much the way Germany was
destroyed one cannot underestimate the
extent to which these two countries were
destroyed you know in the Japanese case
we were fire bombing Japanese cities
starting on March 10th 1945 and we
killed more people the first night we
firebomb Tokyo than were killed in
either Hiroshima or Nagasaki we're
burning Japanese cities to the ground an
incredibly rapid pace
and then we drop two nuclear weapons on
them and there were very few Japanese
cities left that that weren't wrecked
and and they had suffered a devastating
defeat in the war lots of Japanese had
died so this was a wrecked country and
they did believe they too faced the
Soviet threat and you want to remember
that in those days people believed when
North Korea invaded South Korea on June
25th 1950 that North Korea was a Soviet
proxy and people believed in the domino
theory foolish as it was and the
Japanese therefore were very nervous and
of course they were very nervous about
the Chinese as well because the Chinese
and the North Koreans and the Soviets
and the North Vietnamese were all seen
as part of a seamless web these were
people who did not appreciate the
importance of nationalism okay and so
that he had that but also Japan did have
a period where it was a liberal
democracy and that was mainly in the
1920s I don't think it was as
progressive as Germany was by more
Germany but nevertheless I think the
basic ingredients were there the other
case that's raised by the way against me
sometimes are the Eastern European
revolutions in 1989 right because there
you got democracy and the argument the
argument that people like me make is
that that was from the bottom of what
happened in 1989 was not a case of the
United States causing regime change and
helping to create a liberal democracy
it was the collapse of the Soviet Union
and the evacuation of Soviet forces in a
very important way the return of
sovereignty to those countries where
there were powerful Democratic or
liberal democratic forces down below
that bubbled up because I remember in
the context of the Iraq war opponents of
that war like myself argue that things
would go
Souths as i believe they did and many of
the proponents of the war this is the
Iraq war in 2003 would argue that the
experience of the various countries in
Eastern Europe showed that once you got
rid of a dictator right once you got rid
of an authoritarian leader that
democracy would bubble up from the
bottom and of course that did happen in
Eastern Europe but we didn't do it and
and the situation the Middle East was
fundamentally different yes ma'am
but in cases where you do have group of
people that are starting are those
places only democracy could I answer
your first question first just because
I'll forget it I'll answer your second
question - was it the first go ahead go
ahead you could ask both
just on the second part I think what was
going on at home was more important than
foreign policy I didn't mean to oversell
foreign policy I thought I used
qualifying language I was not arguing
that the principal reason he got elected
was that he opposed liberal agenda I
just said it contributed I think your
description is on the money that it was
mainly domestic politics the fact that
there's a large amount of resentment in
this country involving jobs and income
and so forth and so on those kinds of
things I think really mattered more but
I was just saying this contributed to it
and your first question is where do
people fit in and I think you said where
people's preferences fit and especially
preferences for democracy well first of
all I think people are a big part of my
story when it comes to nationalism right
for sure and I understand your point
about preferences and I think if if
people in a particular country want to
become Democratic that's wonderful as I
said in the first lecture my views on
liberal democracy at home are
fundamentally different than my views on
liberal democracy abroad I thank my
lucky stars I was born in the United
States which is a liberal democracy and
I think all things considered I prefer
to live in a liberal democracy than any
other form of political system any other
kind of political system but my argument
is when you take it abroad it leads to
all sorts of problems I tend to favor
self-determination and I believe that if
people want to become democratic that's
up to them right and it's not our
business to go in and influence things
one way or the other and I think you end
up getting into lots of trouble now some
people might say you might say the John
you can do this in a sophisticated way
the problem is that we've behaved in
blunder puss fashion in the past let's
do it in a sophisticated way let's pay
attention to the Preferences of people
in other countries and so forth and so
on I kind of understand that argument
but I think you then run into what I
call the slippery slope problem that
once you get in the business of trying
to promote democracy in other countries
and you're as powerful as the United
States and you're as confident as people
in the United States are about your
ability to do social engineering you're
off to the races and I don't like that
at all so for purposes of promoting
democracy my way of doing it would be to
be the city on the hill and to tie that
in to my last point the argument I was
making is that it's hard to be the city
on the hill when you're intervening all
over the planet in a militarized fashion
because you're undermining liberalism at
home and I am I'm actually a huge civil
libertarian I'm and I think civil
liberties matter enormous Lee and I
think the idea of having a national
security state is frightening you go to
Washington these days it is a national
security state we're addicted to war and
again I'm not against having a military
I went to West Point I was in the
military for ten years of my life I
understand you need a military mind you
have to be very very careful not to turn
the United States into a militaristic
state and I think when you pursue your
more sophisticated defense of liberal
hegemony or promoting liberal democracy
around the world you quickly run into
the slippery slope problem that would
sort of be my argument sir
everybody here is question his view is
basically I have a more or less
reactionary view and that what I'm
talking about in defending the Russians
is basically arguing that we should go
back to a sphere of influences view of
the world and I interpret and I don't
think you would have any trouble with
this I interpret a sphere of influences
type of the world to be basic balance of
power politics right they they go
together right now I believe that you
can't go back to balance of power
politics because we never left them
behind right this is what this is what
we forgot when we moved NATO eastward
balance of power politics was alive and
well not in the United States but in
Russia and it's true in China and it's
true in Iran and it's true in South
Korea right so the idea that this is old
think I mean I think this is the way
most Americans think your view is what I
would call that today the sort of
typical American view of international
politics
we have transcended spheres of influence
right we live in a different world and I
don't believe that for one second
I believe balance power politics is
alive and well and this is why we got
ourselves in so much trouble on Russia
now I just want to unpack this a bit
more talk about the rise of China okay
if China continues to rise
and Russia continues to come back from
the dead we move from unipolarity to
multipolarity or if you want to excise
the Russians and just talk about the
Chinese and the Americans you move back
to bipolarity okay now remember what I
said in the presentation if you're in a
bipolar world or you're in a multipolar
world you cannot pursue liberal hegemony
right so my argument is that if China
continues to rise the United States will
engage in an intense security
competition with China
we're balance of power politics and
spheres of influence matter greatly and
if you go to China today and you talk to
the Chinese about the South China Sea
and the East China Sea and you talk
about the American military presence in
those areas they do not like it because
they view those areas as their sphere of
influence they understand that we got in
there when China was weak but they'd
like to get us out and I would argue
that what you'll see with the United
States is that the United States will
think in terms of spheres of influence
you know what the Monroe Doctrine is
right the Monroe Doctrine basically says
that the United States owns the Western
Hemisphere and no distant great power be
it from Europe or be it from Asia is
allowed to move military forces into the
Western Hemisphere and form a military
alliance with a country in our
hemisphere the Monroe Doctrine which has
not gone away right the Monroe Doctrine
is all about spheres of influence it
says the Western Hemisphere is our
sphere of influence do you think in 25
years if China decides to form a
military alliance with Canada or Mexico
and station a couple Chinese divisions
in Vancouver and Toronto that
we're not gonna go ballistic you're a
young guy so you probably don't remember
the Cuban Missile Crisis unfortunately
I'm not a young guy and I remember the
Cuban Missile Crisis the idea that the
Soviets were putting missiles in Cuba
was completely antithetical to us and
then when they talked about building a
naval base at Cienfuegos we almost blew
another gasket the Soviets are not
allowed in the Western Hemisphere why
because it's an American sphere of
influence why because it's our backyard
well if you're Vladimir Putin or any
Russian leader the idea that NATO is
going to be allowed to drive right up to
your border it's not gonna happen it's
just not gonna happen
you know people will say wow John don't
you understand that the Ukrainians are
free to choose their own foreign policy
you often hear this argument we were
talking about this yesterday the
Ukrainians are free to choose their own
foreign policy their sovereign state
this is not a decision the Russians can
make for them my view is that's a very
dangerous way of thinking about
international politics Ukraine is not a
sovereign state when it comes to this
issue the Russians are not going to
tolerate them form an alliance with NATO
right and if Ukraine behaves like it is
a sovereign state right it's going to
get itself into a well of a lot of
trouble this is what happened to Castro
do you think the United States believed
during the Cold War and even after the
Cold War the Cuba had the right as a
sovereign state to form an alliance with
any state that it chose to we didn't
think that for one second we did not
think that for one second and we went to
great lengths to kill Castro and to
strangle Cuba because Castro thought
that he liked Ukrainians thought had the
right to form an alliance with just any
state when you're dealing with great
powers
this is another election great powers
are ruthless in that states is one of
the most ruthless great powers in modern
history that you cannot underestimate
how ruthless the United States is this
is all covered up in the textbooks in
the classes that we take growing up
right because we hate this is all part
of nationalism nationalism is all about
creating myths about how wonderful your
country is right it's America right or
wrong we never do anything wrong
right if you really look carefully at
how the United States is operated over
time it's really amazing how ruthless we
have been and the British the same is
true of them as well but we cover it up
so I'm just saying if you're if you're
Ukraine and you're living next to a
powerful state like Russia or you're
Cuban and you're living next to a very
powerful state like the United States
you should be very very careful because
this is like sleeping in bed with an
elephant if that elephant rolls over on
top of you you're dead right so you got
to be very careful am I happy about the
fact that this is the way the world
works no I'm not but it is the way the
world works
for better or for worse
[Applause]
[Music]